are you looking forward to destiny too
well then I've got some good news for
you because it looks like its release
date in beta have been leaked I'm Matt
and this gamespot news update may ruin
Activision and bungie surprise an
alleged poster that reveals both the
name and release date for the Destiny
sequel has surfaced on Italian website
leg and network if the poster is
legitimate destiny two releases on
September 8 but it's not the only poster
that's been leaked another one has been
shared on imager and in addition to
featuring similar art it references a
beta that may be available first on ps4
which wouldn't come as a surprise since
the original destiny beta launched first
on PlayStation platforms will report
back when an official announcement is
made so make sure to LIKE and subscribe
to be the first to know about all of the
juicy details destiny to was already
confirmed to launch this year and we
recently learned that your destiny items
and experience won't carry over to the
sequel it's also been reported that the
series will finally make the jump to PC
but that hasn't been confirmed just yet
we'll keep you updated on that front but
if you want some slick sci-fi shooter
action right now check out our video
where we teach you how to create awesome
power combos in Mass Effect Andromeda
[Music]
you